there's another great song you have it's
a duet with blake edwards
i like mike edwards
boy's gonna be mad
what he's gonna be mad at you well
he shouldn't be i once did a little
tribute to him and his wife on this show
oh yeah same thing i was saying about
you and sarandon saying that like if he
could marry gwen stefani and they could
make that work that should be a model to
america if she could marry him well
my point was if red and blue could come
together
people who are not really of the same
backgrounds it could work in their house
it can work in the house of america
anyway
i like him
too i love him yeah and he you know when
they got married it was a very small
affair you know it was covert and all
that they didn't want to invite a lot of
people and i just called him and said i
wasn't going to come anyway you know i
didn't want to see that woman throw her
life away marrying you i wasn't going to
come witness that you know so
i wasn't going to go anyway you know so
but
i know you're kidding but uh not really
but
the song you do with him i love the
title and i love the song
if i was a woman i'd want a man like me
i'd love a man like me uh
um
when you were writing that did you worry
that the other 58 genders that are
represented
on facebook would be offended that they
weren't brought brought into that that
it was not inclusive enough i wasn't
concerned about it at all i don't think
about that you know i actually wrote
that with cherie austin a young lady
great songwriter uh wrote that with
cherie and jeff bates and my dear friend
kenny beard who's passed away now
but yeah no i didn't think about that i
just thought it was funny you know it
was just funny no it's very funny yeah
who won the last election
i'm sorry i do not
but i
sneak that
[Applause]
joe biden won the last election oh
there you go
and this uh you know
what do you think i was gonna say i
don't know but you know i thought joe
biden made a bit of a mistake in the
speech he made a couple of weeks ago
when he talked about magnation because
magga i i've said this for years you can
hate trump you can't hate the people who
like him or voted for him it doesn't
mean they're all crazy doesn't mean
they're all racist doesn't mean they're
all bad people
the people who think that biden
didn't win the election yes they're a
little crazy and they're not factually
based
but
we have to come together we have to be
able to do shows with susan sarandon and
marry gwen stefani
and love each other like you and i do
that's what i'm talking about yeah
you